Can I travel with the right machine? And if so, is it okay to be in the same house as a pregnant woman?
Yes, you can travel with the right machine, just be very careful and wrap it up.
Make sure you're very careful with the bulb. We've had a number of people
send a bulb back, say, their bulb's not working and it's broken on the inside and the ends.
If you drop these bulbs and it falls on a bed and it hits just wrong on its end, it will break the glass
in there and it doesn't look like it's broken. You know, so you're looking at it. I don't see
anything broken. I don't see anything wrong with it, but it doesn't work. And then you open it up
on our side and it's broken. All the gas is gone. It's not going to work. So yeah, do you really,
really careful with the bulbs. The machines are a little bit harder, but again, if you're dropping
the machine or it's bonking through an airplane, you know, you could break it. It's a very delicate
instrumentation on the inside. If you open up the machines, you can see how bonking this thing around
these little tiny wires could break loose. We had somebody ship a machine back to us and there was
multiple broken things though. I don't put all the fault on the person who shipped it back to us
because it went back and forth with the post office and the box was damaged. So I don't know who stepped
on it and who ran over with their truck. But when you open up the box, it was hardly wrapped. So part of it,
the fault had to fall under that person who shipped it back to us. You have to wrap these things
up really good. You have to be really careful with them. So by all means you can travel with your
right machine. I've always traveled with my right machine and have had no problems, but I'm very
careful how you wrap it up. Can you be in the house with the same house as a pregnant woman? Yes, you can.